police are looking for the suspect in a
deadly shooting at the fremont street
experience metro says an argument broke
out inside a downtown casino around two
this morning before it spilled outside
and shots were fired joe muller is
tracking the investigation tonight
fremont street behind us here was
bustling when shots rang out you can
just imagine the commotion one person is
dead and another is injured people we
talked to say it's frightening knowing
this happened at such a busy time
fremont street is typically an area
where people go for fun early sunday
morning it was a crime scene with
caution tape and police an argument
inside a busy casino pushed people to
fremont street where it got violent
right in the middle of a crowd one
subject pulled out a firearm and fired
multiple shots striking the the decedent
and an innocent bystander which is our
which is our
non-life-threatening injury police were
there much of the morning looking for
the shooter and trying to gather
information from witnesses people
visiting downtown say it was a concern i
probably should have been in my room i
didn't need to be out here gabe matrial
is from missouri and was a block down
fremont street when shots were fired he
says he saw police running right after
it happened i'm glad i wasn't there when
it happened but it don't change my
opinion nothing you know i still like
coming down here i'll still come down
here you know but i'll probably go to
bed before two o'clock in the morning
this time i'll tell you that much police
have been looking through security
footage for more information if you are
out here and if you have any information
that could help with the investigation
call police reporting near fremont
street joe mulder live local now